here with reaction former white house
chief of staff mark meadows ohio
congressman jim jordan
uh congressman meadows let me start with
you you were there in the white house
with donald trump
450 plus miles of brand new wall now
kids are being dumped 14
feet down now you see these overcrowded
detention centers frankly i find it
abusive towards these kids
to stay in mexico policy work ending
catch and release worked
and joe biden says this is donald
trump's problem he caused this
i beg to differ well you beg to differ
because
actually joe biden was warned my good
friend jim jordan has highlighted this
the biden administration was warned that
if they did the welcome mat
at the southern border and said
basically we're open for business come
on in
send send anybody from central america
and mexico
we'll let you come on in that it would
create the very crisis that we have here
but this is not just about that this is
about a leftist
agenda and it's about the power the
biden administration can't speak against
this because
they will lose their left and what
happens is
then they lose the power that you were
talking about but they were warned about
this president trump had the right
policy
we need to return to that it'll keep
americans safers and actually it will
keep those coming across our southern
border safer as well
look at those pictures jim jordan those
are three-year-old
three-year-old and a five-year-old being
dumped
you know nearly 14 feet down they hung
him over a little
drop plop good luck you're on your own
kid uh
and then you see the detention centers
now they tried
to keep all the media out they were
successful
we had hannity show cameras with those
19 us senators our cameras were
forbidden from going in
senator cruz lindsey graham ron johnson
tom cotton they gave us those videos
we'll show that in a second
i mean you see the overcrowding you see
the high covert positivity rate
if i ran a daycare center and you saw
those videos
or a state representative saw the videos
what would happen to me
no you'd be in big trouble and it is sad
what these children these women are
going through in this in this journey up
here
but mark's exactly right the president
said you undo my policies there will be
a
tidal wave of illegal immigrants at our
border but sean your monologue was right
on target
this is how crazy today's left is think
about this today you cannot get into
your capital
but anybody and everybody can get into
your country
it is not a crisis on the border it is
chaos on the border and it's chaos
because
they undid the three key policies the
remain in mexico why you're being
processed they undid that
they said no more deportation moratorium
on that and they announced to the world
we will not finish the wall those three
things changed everything and you get
this terrible situation that is causing
harm to kids and women and all kinds of
people
on the border because that's the biden
administration that is how ridiculous
that is how crazy
today's left is all right mark meadows
hr one pack the supreme court and all
the courts
then d.c puerto rico statehood and the
legislative filibuster
and what would that mean to this country
it from
from your point of view well listen joe
biden
is is making sure that our country uh
really is treated like guinea pigs he's
trying to do this progressive socialist
policy
and when he looks at that when you look
at the bills that you were just talking
about
listen they were talking about a
transportation bill
literally they need to be talking about
the freight train that's coming to main
street
america because what they're going to do
is is take the power they're going to
centralize it here in washington dc
you know that hr sr1 that is nothing
more than
taxpayer uh funded trying to keep
politicians in
office they know it and it tilts to
scale
to their benefit and we need to defeat
it because if not
your rights will be taken away from you
and be given to politicians here in
washington d.c
jim jordan we know that in the senate
you need a quorum
there it's a 50-50 senate now to get
that
that's not an instance where the vice
president or some calling president
seems like she's doing all of joe's work
lately um
that kamala harris is not she cannot
break a tie
that means that all of this can end in
the u.s senate if
every republican senator holds a line
and would be willing to walk out of the
chamber
you have confidence lisa murkowski
confidence that mitt romney confidence
of ben sasse
that they would hold the line on that
with with other republican senators
yeah senator mcconnell gave a speech a
couple weeks ago where he said they will
do whatever it takes to stop this
this radical agenda of the democrats and
if they get rid of the filibuster
he's committed to do that i think that
was what was implied in his speech
i think that's the case and frankly it
should happen you know let's also hope
this sean
mark and i always talk about when you
get elected your job is real simple
what'd you tell the voters you were
going to do they gave you an opportunity
to go serve them
do what you said you would do kristen
sinema told us she would not change the
filibuster joe manchin told us they
would not change the filibuster
let's hope they keep their word but if
they don't senator mcconnell had better
do what he talked about doing two weeks
ago
making sure we stopped this radical left
agenda from becoming law
all right jim jordan and mark meadows
thank you both